here's the video put together out of
another ten vu shorts vu being the
now-defunct social network that used
video responses which had to be two
minutes or less 22 comments and
questions and users could write to each
other people could ask questions from
the outside and I've been compiling
these into two videos now I have another
ten more that have to do with ethics but
these have to do with what we might call
issues at the intersection between
ethics and politics or culture where
we're talking about a larger context so
hopefully you'll enjoy these and maybe
they'll provoke some some thought some
conversation some questions some
comments
well this is one which was posted a few
days ago that I have been kind of
putting in the backlog as I think it
more and more about it how would i
define justice I don't have my own
definition I'm content to rely on those
of philosophers of the past and one of
the most common ways of framing at the
ec come up is giving people what is
their do giving everybody what is their
do what what ought to be given to them
rendering on to them what ought to be
now here's the thing when it comes down
to it basically I'm an Aristotelian when
it comes to justice and that means that
I don't think that there is one single
catch-all cover everything definition of
justice I think that there are different
species of justice and Aristotle talks
about about different types of justice
in his different works I think that a
lot of our disputes about justice are
exactly there are subtle says the
different sides of the dispute some of
them get this aspect some of them get
this aspect they don't actually grasp
the whole and they think that they're
grasping the whole which is why they get
so worked up and dismiss their there
our interlocutors and get good things
mixed up a bit I think that justice is
what you can call an analogical term
that it covers a whole family of
concepts and I think that there can be
developments to it additions to it over
time so that for example the notion of
social justice I don't like people who
say that they're all about social
justice because social justice is just
one type of justice it's got to fit
within the matrix of it so if they're
using it to try to bash anything else
that's no good but are there
developments over time new things that
we didn't catch yes
so when we were studying book one of the
Republic this is a big worry for quite a
few of my students they saw this guy
through Simic asst back in you know 4th
century Greece saying hey you know
justice and injustice are basically in
the ein out of the beholder per se but
in the eye of the rich and powerful
people who get to to make that the rules
and they said well you know it looks a
lot awful lot like that today you know
if you look at the marketplace or you
look at politics or you look at you know
celebrities and popular culture it does
seem an awful lot like those who are
able to push their agenda on to other
people who have the means to do so we
have you no force or money or boats or
however you want to put a charisma just
you know ruthlessness those are the
people who actually succeed and those
are the people who get to call the shots
this worries my students an awful lot
and but that's not a new thing that's
been a perennial issue throughout the
ages you know all the way going going
back to the ancient Greeks the fact that
quite often it does work that way
shouldn't be mistaken for something
quite different which is saying that it
should work that way or that one should
just sort of you know buckle under and
say oh okay you got power I'm going to
do what you want who do we look up to
this is one thing you ought to think
about do we look up to those who just
see how things are and then you know
accommodate themselves to it or do we
look up to those who actually take a
moral stand and say yeah in this case
this isn't right maybe this Authority is
legitimate but this authority isn't and
they're doing the wrong thing so I'm
actually going to say something about it
I'm going to do something about it we
look up to those people don't we so that
shows you that through semi kiss doesn't
act
now this is a worry raised by one of my
students in my online ethics class why
should we everyday people ordinary
people right allow authorities to decide
what is right or wrong or good and bad
why do we let it happen so there's a lot
of different questions rolled up at that
and you've got your finger on sort of
the not a lot of different issues that
are there worth exploring and I might
actually talk about this about dr.
Salvin chalking talk there's one pretty
simple answer to this which is that
ordinary people shouldn't allow
authorities right across the board to
decide what's right and wrong or good
and bad that they actually should do
some thinking for themselves now that
doesn't mean that you know we get rid of
authority altogether we say ah authority
figure you're not going to listen to you
period because there may be some cases
where the authority is in fact the
person who has to make the final
decision or where they're better
qualified to make the decision in part
because of their training or their
experience or you know the reason why
they're made into authority but simply
having authority doesn't necessarily
confer upon one anything like moral and
FAL ability or even you know a greater
degree of reliability than
an ordinary person now there you know
you can say it should we allow
authorities in some cases to decide
what's right and wrong or good and bad
and I think yeah in some cases we should
now notice can we leave which cases
should be those in which we do that in
which cases shouldn't be can we leave
that decision up to authorities that's
not a higher level right that's probably
a bad idea because what authorities
typically do they'll tend to assimilate
everything in themselves and say of
course I'm ready to decide all of this
stuff so you know we should probably you
know
when I first read this question I
thought to myself the person must be
mixing up Iraq and Afghanistan because a
lot of people have said that we went to
war with Iraq in terms of oil from that
actually was true of the first Gulf War
to a larger extent if we go on in terms
of oil we'd have been taking that oil
which we did and there were other
reasons we went into Iraq there were
three reasons in the argument for it
Afghanistan we went over there in part
because they were the Taliban were
refusing to give up Osama bin Laden and
the other members of al Qaeda after the
911 bombing you know what I thought
about this I thought boy who doesn't
know that but our students who are
college students now that happen when
they were kids so I could see how they
might not know that that's definitely
something that we're going to have to
keep in mind as the years go by
okay so you have two very interesting
questions here and I think that I am
going to have to put off full discussion
of these two dr. sailor chalk and talk
sessions I'll give you a real quick
response to both is America and other
countries quest to democratize other
countries unreasonable that's an
interesting thing if we go all the way
back to the peloponnesian war in which
you've got this this conflict between
democracy and oligarchy aristocracy
depending on how you want to look at it
one of the tendencies of democracy is to
try to spread itself as a system but one
of the problems with spreading democracy
is if the people over there that you're
now introducing a democracy to don't see
too I to I to you on basic values the
majority of them may decide they want to
kill you and democratic regimes are not
necessarily the most stable regimes
available in the modern era they've
become so but you know there's a big
debate still going on about that because
some totalitarian regimes seem to have
some real longevity as well there was
something called the democracy agenda
that's part of how we got into some of
the adventures that we've been involved
in and this idea was well we would bring
democracy to the Middle East and that's
going to you know diffuse a lot of these
these sort of tensions that are growing
and festering and in places where its
authoritarian rule will religion and
other countries allow for this yes and
no it depends on the interpretation of
the
and where it's really a fundamental
issues with Islam is Islam compatible
with with democracy and that's a that's
an open
that's an interesting question and
that's something that has been done
actually in some Wars and you actually
there's been some movies made about that
but the problem is people who have
committed heinous crimes usually don't
make very good soldiers at all they tend
to be too self-centered and they're not
usually very good in their units so I
would say no probably shouldn't send
people who've been charged with heinous
crimes actually you shouldn't do
anything with people have been charged
right you want to see if they're
actually guilty or not no I don't think
we should send them overseas our
military there's reasons why they don't
take those kind of guys so
what are my thoughts on France's burqa
ban I think that very simply put it is a
sign of a crisis that France and Europe
in general has failed on a very
fundamental level intellectually to
figure out how they're going to deal
with religion which is not going to go
away and how to deal with the connection
between religion and ethnicity and
modernity and if this is the best that
they can produce as a way of trying to
promote enculturation and an
assimilation of religious minorities in
in France it's really quite shameful now
I'm no advocate of you know radical
Islam but you have to understand that
there's many people within Islam that
are very traditionalists that are not
you know radicalized and France like
many of the other European countries has
done a terrible job in bringing them in
and talking about religion in part
because they did a terrible job with
Christianity if you look at the French
you know history going all the way back
to the revolution and then through the
Third Republic they were so hostile to
religion and so triumphal istic in there
there hemming it in that they set it
very bad precedent for thinking through
these sorts of things secularization
does not necessarily mean religion has
to go completely away having a modern
democratic society does not mean that
people have to abandon their religious
identity or marks of it but it's turning
out to be like that in Europe so there's
a real crisis there
yeah I disagree making allowances for
religion would be a huge step backward
for society I'm sure it would be in some
people's eyes and the French model and
for the large part the European model of
secularization you're right but that's
not the only model I actually do think
we have a better model here in America
and actually so did Alexis de
Tocqueville Oh famous Frenchman who
wrote about this in the 19th century you
know we went through something very
similar to this this need to show their
faces to identify themselves business
with some Saudi women who were in a
veiled from from head to toe and we had
to take care of that for passports and
for driver's licenses now there are
workarounds for that what we're talking
about in france is not just being able
to identify people on photos you're
talking about a band all together and
this is part of a larger process which
has tried to outlaw any sort of you know
religious emblems or marks of identity I
just shows a hostility to religion and a
lack of understanding of the importance
of religious identity to too many people
and that's um going back in France a
long ways i mean the era that i do
research on the Catholic philosophers
were excluded from the philosophical
establishment one of the guys that I
work on Maurice blondell after
publishing his dissertation he was
forbidden to teach for two years because
he was Catholic and his dissertation
touched on that they kicked the
religious orders out you know in the
early 1900's Francis got a long history
of this sort of thing so I don't buy the
it's just a matter of identifying
yourself sort of line this is this is a
symptom of a larger problem there's a
lot of good things about France this
isn't one of them
so what I assume that you're talking
about would be showing or releasing a
photo of Osama bin Laden's corpse right
because they've been showing photos of
him all day long some of the stock
photos that we've had before given the
camouflage with the turban or standing
in a very tall next to other people
would it be a wise decision to release a
photo of his body in order to prove his
death or will this cause more problems
good question I think that as far as
ordinary people go you probably don't
need it and as far as radical Islam
assists or you know as I i prefer the
term totalitarian Islam assists go I
don't think that you have to convince
them either that that we've actually
killed him because first off he's been
thrown out of the loop in a lot of
circles for quite a while and second he
did it you know matura clean affords
them a chance to have another
high-profile martyr I guess the people
that it would be a matter of reaching
would be the nascent conspiracy
theorists right and it wouldn't matter
if you showed them a photo because then
they would they would have all sorts of
responses like the photo is dr. door
that's not him or you know any variety
of different different things to dismiss
it so I don't think that it would
actually be helpful to provide any any
photo I think it wasn't smart to do the
burial at sea because they should have
known that provoke all sorts of
questions but what's done is done and
you know I mean the same same thing
would have come up if we said while his
body was blown to bits by
something like that so so that's my take
well the obvious knee-jerk answer a
professor and academic somebody makes
use of libraries as much as I do ought
to be no we should never ever ever ever
ever ever banned books but that's um not
what I actually think I think that there
there's some legitimate purposes for
banning certain books I also think that
something that's very important to
clarify from the start is the difference
between banning books and in the sense
of actually saying you cannot have this
book this book cannot be located in this
building you can't check it out from
here you know those sorts of things a
distinction needs to be made between
that and saying look rekha to purchase
this book we have X amount of dollars
there's a lot of different things we
could purchase there's there's always
more things many many many more things
available for libraries than they're
able to purchase so you know placing
something lower down in the scale of
preferable attea or something like that
we're even saying look you know so long
as conditions are what they are we're
not going to buy this book I don't see
that is exactly the same thing as
banning books even if the motive of the
person is to say look we would never buy
this book if it's being if a decision is
being made about where to allocate
resources that's not quite the same as
banning should there be a rating system
that would be kind of nice but I see all
sorts of difficulties in putting
together the nuts and bolts of a rating
system like that but something like that
could be could be useful for for
libraries it's all fairly loosey-goosey
right now isn't it a lot of lot of
subjective decisions being made so
there's my take as somebody uses an
awful lot of libraries